That was the first criterion adequacy. The second property three criterion is
totality. That is our implementation can't put us in a concrete state that
doesn't correspond to an abstract one. No memory fault core dump messages.
Memory fault core dump would be a concrete state. Okay? And
it doesn't correspond anything in our spec. And we want to prevent such
situations from arising. We call this criterion total or
totality because we must make sure that the retrieve function is total in
the mathematical sense. That it's defined at every point. Here is how this
property looks if we express it formally. For every concrete state t,
if the invariants are true on t, then it had better be the case that there
exists, some kind of abstract state s. That's the result of retrieving out of t.
And the invariants of the abstract invariants must hold on, on state s.